a lot of politicians like to engage in
political grandstanding but nobody did
it like former governor and current
presidential candidate Mike Huckabee he
appeared in Kentucky alongside Davis as
she was released from jail rallying the
crowd with sound bites like these but if
you have to put someone in jail I
volunteer people will continue to mix up
religious freedom in public and private
institutions Davis wasn't the head of a
private business who could refuse
service to anyone she was an elected
public figure who issued public
documents to citizens she had a
directive from the highest court in the
land and she chose to break the law you
may not have known this but Kentucky
wasn't prepared for the gay marriage
decision in places like North Carolina
lawmakers wrote new law to allow for
conscientious objectors to gay marriage
essentially those that didn't want to
marry a gay couple didn't have to but
the government had to provide someone
who would Kentucky didn't have that oops
jailing someone who is engaged in what
is essentially a nonviolent protest
isn't the best course of action no
amount of force is going to get Davis to
comply an issue gay marriage licenses
also if this rally is any indication
Davis's long hard days in the slammer
may have just made it her murder the
rallying cries from GOP candidates on
Kim Davis means gay marriage is back on
the docket for the GOP they're going to
talk about it they're going to raise
money on it and expect it to come up in
the next debate Kim Davis is a TV star
and candidates know if they talk about
her they will get more air time and in
turn they'll get more name recognition
and in turn more BS for you and me we
will not surrender to the tyranny of one
branch of government